[Music]  but a lot of buzz about Ben Affleck  being cast as Batman some Batman fans  think that Ben doesn't have what it  takes I personally disagree once again  we got our hands on another leaked scene  from the movie you don't think that's  possible  that we would actually be able to get  our hands on a leaked scene while we did  here it is I think it's great you are  moving the city and you're gonna like it  [Music]  [Applause]  I have to say I really like that Batman  now wears a crewneck sweater that's  right nothing strikes fear nothing  strikes fear into the heart of a villain  like a crewneck letter that's weird  casting with Catwoman though they're  trying to mix it up all right I'm just  trying to mix it up okay